this is a hot little number oh thank you
girlfriend is not on the Ranch anymore
she in New York City yeah Monica's got
to dress up sometime exactly oh my gosh
okay what is the best part about being a
part of the number one show on
television my friend oh man these people
right here yeah and I feel like really
it's really exciting to be all together
in New York and celebrating it'll be a
fun night absolutely okay give me
breaking off three words to describe
season five oh my goodness okay well
this is my go-to is I I just say worth
the wait worth of okay awesome I'll give
it to you okay I'll give it it's reused
but I think it works and it is I mean
see or season one episode one
wow so many feels so many feels so many
feels
um we've got look rip and Beth this
season finally married yes I mean even
though it was like a shotgun kind of
wooden situation perfect for them truly
it just that was them you know what I
mean and then we've got you and Casey
y'all expecting your second child of the
two relationships of course you might be
a little partial who do you think will
stand the test of time and Go the
Distance oh my goodness you know I I
think they're both forever but in in
totally different ways you know one is
just it's just so meant to be and then
the other one are they're fighting
Against All Odds to be together yeah I
feel like you and Casey your souls are
just like so intertwined in so many
different levels you know what I mean oh
yeah but my goodness have they they've
had a wild ride yes they have and that
hussy that came into the mix oh my God
she needs to get out of here listen I
mean I think she's really pretty I get
it
I may not get it but she gots to go for
sure now fancer speculating and kind of
worried look this this next season we're
getting 14 episodes we're so pumped
about it but they're being divided up
into two halves so what gives with that
we're a little concerned like are we
nearing the end of Yellowstone what if
Kevin and Taylor shared with y'all about
how much longer maybe Yellowstone will
be thriving yeah you know I mean they
haven't given us a number but I think
that nearing the end you know we've got
a story to tell and we don't want to
drag it on too long we want we really
you know we want to do a good job for
y'all absolutely how much longer would
you love to play Monica though oh my
goodness well I've given her a lot of my
20s
um but no no I I mean we love these
characters so much so listen I'll I'll
play as long as I can yeah
foreign